[Music]
2016 called and it wants its resolution
back which was apparently 1080p Nvidia a
company that previously paid influencers
to make videos about 8K gaming on 30 90
cards is now marketing its new 400 RTX
4060 for 1080p
great the RTX 4060 TI 8 gigabyte is one
of the worst GPU launches from Nvidia
that we've ever covered and we don't
want to waste any much time here so
here's how it scales it's anywhere from
negatively scaled against the 3060 TI or
effectively equal once you sort of
normalize for error which is a really
bad place to be up to maybe 19 or 20
percent at the very best and that is
scaling the range of 1080p to 4K there's
a reason Nvidia wants to focus on 1080p
here we tested all the games that we
usually test at 1080 1440 and 4K and as
the resolution increases the performance
falls off a cliff and plummets into
Oblivion so deeply into Oblivion we were
waiting for the Imperial Guard to show
up stop right there criminal scum nobody
breaks the law in my watch the launch is
just straight up bad it's that simple
and we covered in our news video how
Nvidia went short with the bus width for
the memory interface and how the memory
bandwidth is reduced we presented their
defenses is in that news video talking
about how they say it's all about the
extra cash making up for that change and
while that may be true in some instances
realistically uh it didn't matter so we
got to test their claims today we
brought you this video with
store.camersaccess.net and our 15-year
anniversary limited foil shirt we expect
to run out within the next week and will
not be making another run of these our
goal is to bring more journalism the PC
hardware and that's funded largely by
our audience and this year has been
bigger than ever for that our 15-year
shirt has supported many of our recent
efforts such as the introduction of the
gamers.nexus hardware failure list the
front features a vibrant bright blue
foil mixed with a gold 15 plus some
green accents for GPU components the
back of the shirt has a subscriber graph
starting in 2008 when we launched the
website and it moves towards 2 million
now grab one of these shirts before
they're gone and support our interviews
with experts like this one by going to
store.cam access.net considering one of
nvidia's marketing slides from its
initial announcement was talking about
what percentage of Gamers play at 1080p
uh it's no surprise that they then
focused on 1080p but the card is 400 and
just to remind everyone before your gas
lit into believing something else Nvidia
was marketing the GTX 1060 for high
quality 1080p gaming the GTX 1060 came
out in 2016. so
you there's a little bit of a sliding
scale here or actually more
appropriately there's moving goal posts
where resolution was once the thing that
drove sales of the high end in order to
push high-end say 1080 TI or 20 series
sales the move was towards not just RT
at the time which wasn't established yet
but rather 4K gaming when rasterized and
that's especially true for something
like the 1080 TI but as RT has pushed
into the market and more appropriately
as game developers have become lacks in
optimization for some of the titles that
are coming out today the resolution
argument has fallen off and instead the
focus shifts to anything else that looks
more favorable that is no longer
nvidia's focus and that's fine but it
still has to scale it's okay for the
technological Focus to shift to some
other Graphics technology that's more
relevant or more interesting or whatever
but that needs to be defended sensibly
and the 3060 TI equating the 4060 TI and
some of these scenarios or the two
having barely enough of a gap to justify
anything more than overclock in your
3060 TI that's the problem and av1 and
DLS S3 are basically the only things
that prop up the 40 series 60 SKU as
being even a new generation it would
deceptively look like the past
generation otherwise so this is an
embarrassingly impotent GPU and we're
putting a lot of the conclusion today up
front
because the conclusion is is very
straightforward and once again we don't
want to waste anyone's time uh we'll
have all the charts to support that
though but in the news video we're not
going to go back into depth again in the
news video we covered the details of the
changes we covered in videos Arguments
for them presenting them neutrally
objectively now we get to test those but
the main thing was the 128-bit memory
interface and uh typically you'd see
something like a two times that width if
not more at this price class so nvidia's
focused then being on low resolutions
might make sense and we started with the
focus on 1080P and the charts you're
about to see but we shifted that to
front load in 1440 and 4K because
realistically 1440 is probably what
you're expecting to play at this price
class and the FPS does support it but
the more interesting thing to us
technologically was as an academic study
how does the scaling behave between
these resolutions uh because we became
suspicious based on some of the things
that Nvidia said okay we're gonna get
into the testing so competing cards to
think about the 6700 XT at least has a
writing and filming is available for
around 320 at the lower end of the price
stack up to 350. so that's very
competitive against the 400 8 gigabyte
4060 TI there's a 500.46 DTI 16 gigabyte
coming out in July there's a 40 60
non-ti coming out in July 300 but the 16
gigabyte nothing changes except for the
memory capacity and in instances where
the memory itself is not the limitation
and there are instances where memory was
limitation will show some footage now of
control at 4K where the textures were
failing to load on the 4060 TI and that
was a capacity problem but in instances
where that's not the limit the issue is
the power is still not going to be there
to drive the performance the 6800 XT
very interesting 500 to 550 right now on
average seems like it's running low on
Supply but that will be the competitor
to the 16 gigabyte 4060 TI the 7600 is
rumored to be about 300 the a750 is like
250 dollars now the 6600 XT 255 these
are lower price options they're not
going to compete in performance the 4060
TI but that gives you the landscape of
the market and then above it it's the
4070 whose MSRP was 600 but maybe it's
starting to come down anyway it launched
at 650 higher than the 4060 TI's launch
price so uh the performance will not
scale with that price hike but let's get
into the chart in Total War Warhammer 3
at 1080p the RTX 4060 TI eight gigabyte
card ran at 129 FPS average with lows at
96 and 71. this has the 600.40 70 priced
50 higher running about 35 ahead the
prior 3060 TI it ran at 120 FPS average
establishing only an eight percent lead
for the 4060 TI over the 3060 TI This
truly is revolutionary you actually
couldn't get this much generation to
generation consistency if you tried
nvidia's performance here is phenomenal
terminal very impressive they were able
to Flat Line a card from 60 to 60 and
show an improvement that basically
amounts to noise you could overclock a
card and get eight percent even another
eight gigabytes of video memory can't
save this GPU its impotence is
insurmountable from Simply vram it needs
much more than that Intel Arc in that
chart meanwhile is sitting on these
charts wondering where its price
competitors have been for the past year
it's finally gotten some but they're
mostly older cards the 6700 XT is
regularly 320 to 350 on NewEgg right now
brand new making the 4060 TI 25 more
expensive but only also eight percent
higher in performance the value is not
good at 1440p the 4060 TI really shows
up strong it's
2.68 better than the 3060 TI not 2.67
certainly not 2.69 percent but 2.68 now
that's impressive but again it's hard to
get some of these games to be consistent
with a 2.68 let alone nail it an entire
generational leap apart the 6800 XT
outperforms the 4060 TI by a staggering
41 and that's available for around 500
to 530 now or the same price as the
future 16 gigabyte 4060 TI and now we
are learning the power of memory
bandwidth and bus width despite nvidia's
cash boost something that they focused
on heavily in our interview where we
previously detailed nvidia's answers to
why some of these changes despite that
boost the scaling just gets worse as the
resolution increases and this is just an
insult at this point like we're
1080p gaming was a thing that we
targeted
six seven eight probably eight it's
about eight years ago with much cheaper
cards and uh this one is already failing
to scale at 1440 but let's take it up
one more run there was a time when these
companies were pushing for 4k on 400
cards but we have to keep moving that
goal post otherwise people won't need to
buy new cards game developers
fortunately can help with that by not
optimizing anything but in this instance
4K serves as an academic study the RTX
4060 TI ran at an academically low 38.8
FPS average making it actually worse
than the 3060 TI this is just
embarrassing this is basically error to
be fair but basically error is a
terrible place to be for a generational
change not a good look for NVIDIA and
we're seeing the limitations of bus with
that play cash increase or not this just
isn't good enough the last data point is
so important that we're going to switch
Focus to validating it the 3060 TI
matching or potentially outperforming
the 4060 TI at 4K is deeply concerning
there's some corporate words that Nvidia
should understand and so we're front
loading the 4K test now for this train
wreck the words that the audience will
understand and Rainbow Six Siege which I
think we all agree should be able to
play 4K on a 400 video card the game ran
at 126 FPS average on the 4060 tiat in
an absolute sense uh okay it's playable
in a relative sense compared to the 3060
TI's 121 FPS average and with one
percent point one percent lows being the
same between them that's once again just
straight up embarrassing this card may
very well be dead on arrival and the
worst card that Nvidia has produced in
years that's about a four percent
Improvement generationally same price or
not we're in Intel Skylake on Skylake on
Skylake levels of Limp product the 6800
XT posts far higher performance and
should probably be grabbed prior to the
4060 TI 16 gigabyte launching at the
same price at 1440p the 4060 TI posted a
261 FPS average with lows well spaced
and timed behind it so at least it's
consistent there it is however also
consistent in being an embarrassing let
down the 40 70s about 31 ahead despite a
50 price increase and the 3060 TI now
allows the 460 TI a lead of five percent
so that's great it's gotten one
percentage Point better at 1440p surely
this justifies its existence to someone
somewhere we're at waste of sand levels
of bad and rapidly descending soon it
will be just a waste of molecules at
1080p the RTX 4060 TI should unembarrass
itself just a little bit that's a new
word by the way unembarrassed we're
coining it here kind of like how Nvidia
coined unlaunched not long ago the 4060
TI's 421 fpsr which is only one FPS
higher than what you'd have to be using
to conceive of this product the result
has it at 7.5 better than the 3060 TI
that's 2.5 percentage points increase or
if you work for nvidia's marketing
department you could call it a 50
increase
it's math marketing math this result has
the 40 70 maintaining a familiar spacing
the 6700 XT is encroaching on the 4060
TI but not as much as the 3060 TI in
this game so once again incredibly
unexcited and they'd have been better
off just making more 30 60 tis but
that's not really a great outcome either
time to continue now with the newer game
in cyberpunk 2077 at 4K Nvidia makes a
miraculous recovery one that parallels
only no man's sky and it lays claim to
an impressive staggering 5.4 percent
improvement over the 30 60 TI this is a
this is actually like
this is actually unbelievable
it's like bad
we were worried for the first half of
this review but that worry has been
quelled they've done it they've made the
worst 400 generational Improvement ever
to launch in this industry the 4070 only
posts an 11 improvement over the 4060 TI
here allowing disproportionate leads on
other Hardware North of these 40 series
cards at the quote-unquote low end for
peasants and Poor's who can't wear a
leather jacket everywhere the 6800 XT
pulls a 23 lead over the 40 60 TI 8
gigabyte card perhaps threatening the
later same price 16 gigabyte model just
just kidding it's not perhaps definitely
definitely threatening it but don't
worry we still have 1440p to lean on a
resolution that Nvidia boasted being
able to run on its same priced cards
from the Pascal generation the RTX 4060
TI ran at 66 FPS average here leading
the 3060 TI by 6.5 percent one of the
biggest increases we've seen all review
the 4070 leaves 28 percent ahead so
that's a big jump from its prior
hindrance this generation seems
disproportionately poor in 4k
performance and to some extent 1440
maybe that's why Nvidia is pushing the
LSS and RT so hard they need to get
people running the lower true pixel
counts to play to the strengths of the
architecture at 1080p the 4060 TI is 106
FPS average puts it just ahead of the
6700 XT the lead over the 3060 TI grows
to 9.8 percent maybe that's the trick to
all of this the scaling here suggests
that if we just drop the resolution to
360p maybe 144p it might be in territory
where we see reasonable generational
gains
but right now this truly is it's it's
reliving has well into Skylake and if
you were there you know how boring that
was until Intel had a competitor again
this is just it's this is bizarre it's a
the newest high-end
144p gaming card get your quake and
unreal tournaments ready here we go back
to the Chart the 6800 XT is 140 FPS
average posts a compelling option in the
500 price class even with the impending
500 40 60 TI that no one is going to
care about after this one there's not
much else to say here they've relaunched
the 3060 TI we haven't found the worth
yet so we're gonna go into the shadows
of tombs to continue to not find it in
Tomb Raider at 4K the 4060 TI's
performance posted good frame time
pacing so that's a positive the one
percent and point one percent lows are
performing as expected but the 66 FPS
average has it once again shockingly bad
in positioning against nvidia's own
prior product if this thing didn't have
av1 we wouldn't believe it's even Ada
architecture it seems like they actually
just released a refresh of the 3060 TI
and clocked it up we're talking about
three FPS here this is ridiculous we
could do that by spending 15 minutes
overclocking or like putting it under an
air conditioning unit or something Intel
Arc has been below this price class
alone for months now and even its a750 a
card now a sub three hundred dollars is
within 30 percent of the 4060 TI Nvidia
is contributing to one of the best
marketing campaigns that Intel could
hope for after the melting x3d CPUs and
this disaster's launch all Intel has to
do is stay stay quiet and its products
will sell themselves thanks Steve at
1440p the 126 FPS average performance
lifts the 4060 TI to be about 12 percent
ahead of the 3060 TI that's at least
closer to nvidy's own first party
embarrassing claim of 15 Headroom no
wonder they were so shy about pushing it
and pushing the lss3 so hard this card's
only Advantage is that the 30 series
doesn't support dlss3 but not every game
has the lss3 support and not every gamer
wants to use it anyway the 6700 XT
technically leads the 4060 TI here as
well and the 6800 XT posts a big enough
lead to be secure against the inbound
4060 TI 16 gigabyte finally at 1080p the
4060 TI starts to show where it does
kind of better we wouldn't call it doing
well but we'd at least classify it as
not so embarrassing as to question
sanity it's our new award we'll post it
on a website or something the 4060 TI's
187 FPS average has its 17 percent ahead
of the 3060 TI that's still product
refresh territory for an improvement
except that's a new architecture it's
kind of like a 30-65 TI or something but
this one is at least less
catastrophically brand credibility
imploding than some of the previous
results everything from 225 FPS and up
is hitting a hard limit so you can
ignore those entries they mean nothing
just like the 4060 TI because Nvidia
came to this review equipped with a
shovel we decided to use it to dig GTA 5
out of the Grave before putting this one
in it we only ran at 4K because we
thought a game from 2015 from 2013 would
be too light to run at 1440p we were on
evidently because the 4060 TI sat firmly
at 72.9 FPS average this older title
combined with 4K produced a shockingly
poor results for NVIDIA the 3060 TI's 77
FPS average is 5.9 percent ahead of the
4060 TI that's just awful we thought it
was wrong we looked into it and uh it
wasn't it's just probably this bus
problem once again the lows aren't even
any different between these so the top
of this chart is CPU bound but certainly
the 4060 TI is not after that expedition
to the graveyard it's time to enter
nvidia's Final Fantasy of a product
worth considering and look at end Walker
in this test at 4K the 4060 TI ran at 64
FPS average with lows not particularly
good but also not disproportionately bad
from the rest of these results the a770
encroaches on nvidia's spot hard here
and in a way that's concerning for
NVIDIA it's cheaper it has the most gas
left in the tank when it comes to driver
improvements nice that was an unintended
pun and Nvidia has already exhausted its
driver tricks with how mature its cards
are the 3060 TI is within error of the
4060 TI not a surprise at this point
sadly the 6800xt meanwhile proves what
worthy of consideration once again at
1440p the scaling is at least favorable
enough to push the 4060 TI back in front
of the 3060 TI the memory bus was
hurting it at 4K and the 46 DTI moves to
about 6.4 percent lead over the 360 ti
so this is getting predictable let's
just move on the frame cap at 1080p is
bound by the CPU it ends up being about
225 FPS average we removed all the other
cards Bound by that the 4060 TI is up
there but it retains its six percent
lead over the 3060 TI we were hoping to
see a little bit more scaling here but
not this time we're going to move
quickly now F1 2022 at 4K had the 4060
TI at 74 FPS average which is six
percent ahead of the 3060 ti so they at
least look better here than in some of
the previous results the 6700 XT is is
just ahead of the 4060 TI at 4K with the
40 70 once again about 33 ahead at 1440p
the 4060 TI ran at 133 FPS average which
had at 9.7 percent ahead of the 3060 TI
finally we're starting to find nvidia's
claims of uplift the 6700 XT maintains a
lead now reduced to 3 percent though at
1080p which is the resolution that this
disgrace was marketed for the 4060 TI is
again about nine percent ahead of the
3060 TI which actually is just bad it
didn't keep scaling so once again you
could overclock a 3060 TI and split the
difference or achieve it let's do one
more set of rasterization just to prove
the points it's just just to have enough
games in here because the beatings will
continue until the benchmarks improve in
Horizon zero Dawn at 4K the 4060 TI ran
at 59 FPS average with a 30 60 TI
slightly ahead we've shown this in
enough games to prove the point that 4K
is just hard for the 4060i to prove it's
worth which is severely disappointing
CNN video was pushing for 4K at points
not distant from this one not many years
ago in fact these numbers have been so
unexpected that our lab technicians on
this review Jeremy and Patrick marks the
results as suspicious for me to look at
we re-ran the tests to ensure it wasn't
test error and it kept coming up the
same at 1440p the 4060 TI outpaces the
3060 TI by a staggering of 1.1 FPS
average remarkable they've done it we
can all go home this is it it's the
Pinnacle of the mid-range time to move
on to Ray tracing benchmarks with Ray
Trace Shadows enabled for Tomb Raider
and first at 1080p the 4060 TI slightly
redeems itself with an 18 boost over the
3060 TI when tested in a proper like for
like scenario with rt enabled on both
based on nvidia's claims that's the
number we'd want to see in all of these
scenarios but it's not in all of them
that's the problem the 6800 xt's lead is
19 here with the 4070s still reliably 33
to head at 1440p the 4060 TI ran at 75
FPS average leading the 6700 XT This
Time by 11 the 3060 TI 65 FPS reduces
the 46 dti's lead to 15 from its prior
18 lead which follows a known Trend the
only reason we're showing this at 4K is
because it's like a train wreck you
can't look away from the lead is now
only eight percent over the 3060 TI
we're back to where we started it's not
about the absolute numbers but about the
relative numbers the lead continues to
reduce with resolution increases the
6800 XT now climbs to a staggering 40
lead with the 40 70 at 50 ahead from 33
previously the bus appears to matter
more than Nvidia was letting on moving
on to control nvidia's wants Flagship
poster child RT title the 4060 TI is 75
FPS average result and its lows but it
has basically tied with the 3060 TI
there's a gap of about 3.3 percent here
now control was pretty rough on the
memory bus this is something we're going
to talk about more in a moment because
there's some texture loading issues and
being harder on the memory bus maybe
shows why the Gap is really not that big
at 1080p the 6800 XT holds a 24 lead
threatening the incoming 40 60 TI 16
gigabyte one important note although the
6600xc is present here it does not have
sufficient memory performance to load
all the textures the other eight
gigabyte cards were not necessarily
problematic at 1080p but they were at
higher resolution 1440p is basically the
same the 60 tis are within one FPS
moving on we won't bother showing the
chart from 4K but here's some footage
the 4060 TI was incapable of loading the
textures properly at 4K and if he played
for long enough at 1440 we suspect it
would also be a problem now this isn't
just the bus but in fact is vram
capacity its performance is bad enough
that this is acceptable behavior
considering RT's presence just as an FPS
number how however we wanted to point it
out because although it is quote unquote
acceptable in the sense of well RT is on
and it's pretty heavy and it's 4K it's a
vram problem unfortunately a 24 FPS
results with unloaded textures won't
support even a 16 gigabyte card in this
game and unloaded textures means it
might influence the frame rate in a
positive direction anyway it might load
textures next time but with 16 gigabytes
and no other changes on the next 4060 TI
it still won't perform enough to matter
in this particular game Ray tracing for
F1 at 1080p had the 460 TI 83 FPS
average which is a 14 lead over the 3060
TI that's much more normal but still not
really convincing the trend continues
we're nvidia's newer card may be
advantaged in RT but even still 14 isn't
enough to be particularly exciting at
least this one didn't have texture
issues or vram capacity issues though
and now we move to cyberpunk with Ray
tracing at 1080p we're using dlss and
FSR Technologies here Intel AMD you're
on FSR and videos using dlss2 scaling is
in the chart header and is like for like
the 4060 TI ran at 97 FPS average
leading the 360 TI by 18 with a like for
like dlss setting to see more DLS S3
impact you can see our prior cyberpunk
RC overdrive content the 6800 XT now
falls behind with the 79xc and XTX leads
also shrinking in this scenario Nvidia
is advantaged in general our thermal
chart features a 30 minute Port Royal
Loop this allows the GPU to hit steady
state thermals so that allows us to
evaluate the cooler performance the
frequency Behavior the fan responds and
how it does with a sustained load for
thermals the GPU core in this chart
ended up averaging at around 62 to 65
degrees Celsius in a controlled 21
degree celsius environment the GPU
hotspot was more variable ranging from
70 to 76 degrees Celsius these numbers
are okay the Delta from core to hotspot
is about 10 degrees on average which is
better than typical for GPU coolers at
least for are the ones that we used to
get this indicates that Nvidia has
established even pressure distribution
and contact between its GPU cold plate
which we'll look at in the teardown
posting later today and the GPU die
itself this specific aspect of cooling
is something that Nvidia has been
working at you can stack as much copper
as you want but if it's ineffectively
leveraged and it doesn't make good
contact it doesn't really matter
Partners could learn from this focus and
it's something that some of them picked
up on but not all of them and maximizing
pressure distribution will better
leverage designs the 4070 Fe Justice
reference point ran similar Deltas but
with an increased Baseline temperature
of about three to five degrees briefly
looking at Fan RPM the card ramps from
zero to 1500 RPM almost instantaneously
once the load starts it's not really
much latency or hysteresis there then
always type and the noise at level are
therefore relatively consistent once the
load is established next up is a
frequency validation plot to make sure
things are working properly we Zoom this
scale in to make the differences more
visible and the RTX 4060 TI held about a
2760 megahertz clock throughout the
entire test there were really no drops
in frequency here other than a couple
blips and no Decay from thermal soak
that's one of the main things we look
for is if the cooler starts to get
overrun the RTX 4080 ran at 2780
megahertz on average with the 40 90
fluctuating more between 2700 and 2780.
power testing is up now the new RTX 4060
TI should be a low power consumer
compared to previous generations and
that follows a couple of nvidia's recent
trajectories one of them is the relative
performance to price trajectory where
the expensive mid-range cards have only
gone down in relative performance to
price so it kind of makes sense that the
power consumption is also going down
because we're shuffling the whole stack
down in the naming Department the 4060
TI pulled about 165 watts and a full
torture workload with a power virus so
that's the worst case scenario that
hasn't below the prior 3060 TI by about
40 watts and about 30 Watts higher than
the RX 6600 the RTX 4070 ran at 200
Watts for the same workload or a 20
increase in power consumption and we'll
look for scalable performance gains to
compare against that overclocking only
added another 10 watts to the 4060 TI
which is a massive disappointment and
another demonstration of almost no
overclocking Headroom on a Founder's
Edition card so at least this is an
aspect that Partners could improve on
and it's one where if they improved too
much maybe it would start sort of taking
away an argument for an upsell to a
higher end card so the GP is kind of
embarrassing the best argument here
would be DLS S3 which is the argument
Nvidia made and focused on and now we
understand why there was so much
resistance when we said why don't you
just add another bar to the chart
where it's tested like for like DLS S2
or no dlss or whatever but doing first
party benchmarks where it's dlss3
against the 3060 TI with dlss2
it stood to it was misleading by our
opinion Nvidia disagrees with that and
that's fine but it's not a life-for-like
test and that much is not disagreeable
there's there's a forced agreement there
because it's fact so DLS has three uh
while yes available on the 4060 TI is
not sufficient to justify its existence
in this capacity it is a waste of sand
and uh in that way we just can't
recommend it it's
this is not is the prices are falling
right now it's really frustrating to see
cards like this launch because
it starts to become clear why the
community has been saying well so the
names are shifting and although names
are in some part arbitrary and there was
a time years ago that I more believed
well the product name is arbitrary who
really cares about the performance over
the past year I'd say we've posted a
video where I wanted to detail on the
4080 being on launched why actually I
now disagree with my own old statement
and that's because although the names
are in one aspect arbitrary it is as
we've mentioned before a death of the
author scenario where it is not
arbitrary to the buyer and that's what
matters that's the mindset that Nvidia
lacks which is the name 4060 carries
with it at least some level of
expectation some level of although not
as high as an 80 class Prestige and it
lacks that here it behaves more like say
a 40 50 and launching a card that is
functionally equivalent to at times up
to 20 better than the last generation
similarly names product at the same in
price while yes Noble Nvidia thank you
for not increasing the price it's just
not good enough and that's all we really
have to say about this card uh maybe the
4060 will turn it around for NVIDIA we
don't really know we'll have to test it
but the 16 gigabyte is unlikely to solve
these problems it will solve the issue
of textures not loading in games like
control which are more memory intensive
in terms of capacity it will not solve
raw throughput problems because it
doesn't change the the compute
capabilities so
that's it for this one I check back soon
we'll probably have an RX 7600 review
that's supposed to launch pretty soon as
well according to the rumors and
otherwise subscribe for more go to
store.gamersexis.net support this type
of coverage directly we're cramming all
this testing and filming right before
our flight for a couple of weeks in
Taipei to cover computax which is a
massive really fun trade show with a lot
of new computer hardware added and uh we
won't really be covering GPS that much
so you'll probably like it check it out
but we'll see you all next time